the charity christian aides says the 10
worst climate disasters this year have
cost 140 billion dollars
in insurance claims bushfires in
australia caused five billion dollars in
losses
and killed more than a billion wild
animals while on the u.s
west coast wildfires caused 20 billion
dollars worth of damage
over in china flooding in the yangtze
river basin led to 32 billion in losses
but extreme weather events linked to
climate change had a disproportionate
effect
in poorer countries six of the ten
costliest disasters were in asia which
was hit by some of the strongest storms
on record
and they caused huge human and financial
losses in countries
that bear little responsibility for
global warming including bangladesh
sri lanka and bhutan
and in east africa a massive locust
infection
invasion in fact damaged 8.5 billion
dollars worth of crops now the swarm was
linked to unusually wet conditions
fueled by climate change
catherine cramer is the climate policy
lead at the charity christian he joins
me now
from london good to have you with us on
the programme can we just begin
with the fact that we tend to look at
climate change in terms of cost because
developed countries seem to see the
costs of rebuild
and repair escalate but the cost to
poorer nations
is as acute be it their infrastructure
is cheaper to deal with
yes that's right i mean this report did
look at the 10 most financially
devastating climate-related impacts of
2020
and as you say each of them caused more
than a billion dollars of
ins of losses but i think it's really
important to note
that these were the insured losses and
so the figures we have for developing
countries where the insurance market is
less developed would obviously be
significantly higher
and of course while we list the deaths
that each of these uh storms and floods
and fires have caused
it's the impacts for developing
countries in loss of life
in terms of loss of livelihood and even
loss of possessions
and significantly higher in the sense
that if you don't have much
and you lose it then you've lost a lot
more than if you have a lot and lose
some
indeed climate change and it's sort of
effects have to be dealt with and
we're seeing that the the new us
president-elect wants to lead once again
by reaffirming his commitment to
climate change protocols that must be
quite a relief
it is very much a relief i mean the us
is the biggest historical emitter
and without the us you know it's very
difficult politically to get
other countries motivated because we're
in a situation of the tragedy of the
commons
where climate change is a global problem
and
without those that have caused the most
damage being on board and those that
continue to pollute most
being on board the significant amount of
ambition and efforts put forward
earlier this month by developing by a
lot of developing countries
will just be overwhelmed by the carbon
emissions if we carry on the fossil
economy
in terms of you might say the u.s
omission on the public stages last four
years
what has been lost by their lack of
leadership that
could be regained once uh
president-elect biden takes office
in mid-january i think it's important to
note that the u.s didn't stall all
action there was a huge amount of effort
done by states and cities
and a lot of work done sub-nationally
but without that high-level political
leadership it has been a lot harder to
to get that motivation internationally
without seeing the leadership from the
front by the
one of the world's biggest polluters and
we talked about climate change we're
seeing france and other european
countries talk about electric car
societies
by 2040 in germany by 2030. it's easy
isn't it for developed countries to say
this but where does that leave the
underdeveloped third world
nations mainly for example south asia
where they use rickshaws for example
and petrol and gasoline in their
lighting and heating
well i think this is where we need
global solidarity and for all the
uh kogit 19 has been a global tragedy
there is the opportunity
if we do the economic recovery recovery
packages to do it right
but this needs to be in global
solidarity so that we actually have
not just countries going trying to
stimulate their own economies but trying
to
actually start developing sustainable
development across the globe
and that doesn't involve enabling
developing countries to leap
from the fossil economy we do need to
get out of all fossil fuels
straight into a renewables economy to
transform the transport sector
and some of that will be done by buying
down the costs by actually
getting uh buying the technologies
and as the factories are developed
enabling them to be created more in bulk
things like electric vehicles
but that transition does need to be
supported and also developing countries
need a lot of support for their
adaptation
to build their resilience against the
kinds of climate impacts that we've
talked about in this report
real political face-to-face hard talk
has been difficult during the covet
pandemic
i mean there's much to discuss in
glasgow in 2021 at the next sort of cop
26 gathering what would you like to see
top of the agenda or
what you what do you think is achievable
in terms of
some of the top subjects that could be
discussed at that meeting
well the art of the achievable of course
is down to political will and that's in
the hands of our political masters
but also in the hands of all of us to
try and urge our political masters to
act at the level that we need them to
act
i think some of the big ticket things
that need to be brought forward are
greater emissions reductions pledges
um we had a summit about two weeks ago
that was online where
different countries pledged what they
would bring forward but there were many
of the larger countries that were
noticeable by their
absence obviously the u.s hasn't had its
change of government yet
uh japan has come is due to come forward
fairly soon with a new pledge
but we haven't heard anything from other
g20 countries like russia saudi arabia
and some of the other really big
economies that really do need to be
putting
action on the table but it's not just
pledges we actually need the policies in
place to implement them and to really
start getting
the emissions reductions at the speed
that we can
that they need to be done if we're going
to try and limit global warming to 1.5
degrees
it's really good to get your insight
catherine kramer from christian aid
thanks for joining us from london
thank you very much